ich habe mein Leben lang Spaghetti
alliolio falsch gemacht und ich zeige
euch warum ein Muss für diese pasta
spaghetti in Bronze ausgeformt dadurch
kriegen die so eine geriffelte
Oberfläche geben mehr Stärke ab und
ermöglichen uns erst durch die Stärke
eine richtige Soße hinzubekommen
Nudelwasser ordentlich salzen unsere
Nudeln sind nach 12 Minuten al dente wir
kochen sie aber nur für zehn dann
Olivenöl in eine Pfanne
petersilienstange hineingeben ein zwei
zerschlagene Knoblauchzehen und eine
fein gehackte Chili die ganze Zeit über
hat unsere Olivenöl bisschen gebrutzelt
und Geschmack angenommen das heißt wir
holen jetzt die Knoblauchzehen und die
petersilienstiele wieder raus und jetzt
können wir unsere Nudeln ziehen und in
die Pfanne geben wir geben hier locker
drei vier dicke Kellen Nudelwasser rein
die Feuchtigkeit kocht draußen Stärke
bleibt zurück und genau das bezeichnet
man als emulgieren weil jetzt werden Öl
und Nudelwasser zu einer Soße guckt euch
diese Schönheit einfach an wirklich eine
einzige Soße hat sich darüber gelegt und
hatte ich ein bisschen Petersilie klein
für die Farbe ein paar kleine
Knoblauchwürfel dazu jetzt das ganze
noch einmal einem verbinden das sind
Spaghetti aliolio guck dir das an hey jo